so sieht er aus in österreich
so in den arabischen emiraten und so in
deutschland der feind zielscheiben
spiegeln den blick dessen der auf sie
schießt seine vorstellungen vom kämpfen
und sie offenbaren sein feindbild
herlinde koelbl bild zeigen was diese
tage zu über feindbilder heute verraten
weltweit
das militär war völlig überrascht was
will schießt ziele
das war überhaupt kein thema im militär
ist ein waffen dass das ein thema oder
welcher neue panzer oder welche nächste
einsatz
das hat mich alles nicht interessiert an
ich wollte die skis ziele sehen und das
war für die erstmal fast unfassbar dass
jemand so was machen will
eine reiche beute hat ihre expedition
erbracht figuren die an pop art erinnern
doch auch die us-amerikanische fein
figur ivan erhalten aus dem kalten krieg
sieht man in köln bis ausstellung in
zürich
auch wenn er heute nur noch selten
seinen roten stern trägt andere ziele
figuren sind dazugekommen
auffällig oft sind es figuren mit
orientalisch aussehender kleidung
silhouetten die an die kriegsschauplätze
der letzten jahre erinnern an dem
schützengraben delikte feind wir sind
hier und es wird gegeneinander
geschossen
das ist ja alles nicht mehr und früher
war der gegner eindeutig man soldat
uniform gewähr
das ist es nicht mehr es ist der
asymmetrische krieg da gibt keine
fronten mehr
diese nirgendwo und auch der feind ist
irgendwo
in 31 ländern hat sie fotografiert meist
bei staatlichen armeen aber auch bei
freiheitskämpfern wie der polisario in
der westsahara ein immens aufwendiges
projekt ist es geworden dass bald über
das abbilden von zielscheiben
hinausgehen vielerorts fand sie ganze
dörfer für den häuserkampf
sie hielt geisterstädte fest von denen
manche in den usa von hollywood
ausgestattet sind
die heute 77 jährige fotografin reister
allein zugang zur geschlossenen
gesellschaft des militärs fand sie durch
große beharrlichkeit
man muss erst mal eine vorstellung haben
im konzept haben was man was man sehen
hinterher als ergebnis haben will
zumindest grob und dann gilt als erstes
die leidenschaft dazu dass auch wirklich
machen zu wollen und dann kommt die
disziplin dazu aber beides gehört
zusammen nur ohne das eine geht es
andere nicht das ist einfach so
herlinde koelbl ist bekannt für
großprojekte in port reform
ob es menschen in ihren schlafzimmern
sind oder politiker in köln bis
bekanntester serie spuren der macht man
meint sie in den gesichtern der
porträtierten lesen zu können
und so fand die fotografen auch bei
ihrem projekt targets noch zum porträt
zu den menschlichen zielen denn mehr und
mehr trainieren soldaten wie hier in der
schweiz mit laserwaffen und
simulationssystemen das lebende ziel ist
der kamerad konsequent findet kalt ich
habe man immer es möglich war sprachlich
mit den soldaten geredet wir standen ja
die ganzen tag der zusammen und habe sie
gefragt was sie denken welche
erfahrungen sie gemacht haben
über angst über auch über töten das
ganze spektrum was was sie beschäftigt
herlinde koelbls projekt ist keine skis
figuren sammlung
es ist ein parcours durch die welt des
schießens tötens sterbens existenziell
und mitunter auch sehr absurd